[Music]
sam's in baltimore maryland hey sam
welcome to the dave ramsey show
hey dave how's it going better than i
deserve how can we help
all right so uh the the short and sweet
of it is uh i have a car
i'd like to sell it uh buy something in
cash
with the the proceeds of the sale of the
vehicle because i have some positive
equity in it
and then use the money that would have
went to monthly payments for the next
three years
uh to pay down debt and to go towards
retirement
problem is my wife doesn't want me to do
that
your wife doesn't want to get out of
debt well
her opinion is we're going to get out of
debt quick enough without having to do
that and she thinks i'll be i'm happy if
i get rid of my car
i kind of agree with her but
also i think logically and watching your
share over the last couple weeks just
got to in india
it makes more sense to get rid of the
car how long have you been married sam
uh 11 years okay and what other debt do
you have outside of the car
so we have uh 25 000
in credit cards uh we have a debt
consolidation loan
that's about fifteen thousand um i will
say this
we have a about thirty thousand in
inheritance
that we should be receiving in the next
month or so so that's
essentially going to knock it down to
about 10 000 left we have a really good
income
also um so we make about 235 annually
what are you on what do you owe on the
car
so the car i have 32
um my multi payments are about 690.
i could sell it and the value of the car
is about 50. so i'd have
just under about 20 000 to buy something
used
why do you have so much supposed vehicle
equity
did you put a lot of down on this thing
or did you get a great deal
yes not well both um
yeah put a lot down pretty decently
negotiating
and i had quite a bit down okay uh so
let me get this straight
after the inheritance comes in you have
a thirty two thousand dollar car payment
and you have a ten thousand dollar debt
forty two thousand and you make two
fifty
uh two thirty about two thirty five okay
my wife also has a car
it's 30 000. that's at a zero percent
interest rate we just got that
that's we actually put quite a bit down
on that as well
um so i figured i'd throw that in the
picture too
okay so you don't have do you have any
other debt other than we've heard so far
it was like a thousand dollars she still
is for student loans
so that can be paid off pretty quick and
we have a surplus every month of
like around five thousand dollars after
taxes and gas and groceries and bills
and stuff so
that's what i'm saying we can pay these
the loans down but i'd rather
even if we didn't have any debt i'd
rather take that extra money every month
at 690
and put more towards retirement
okay um here's what i'm hearing
you're not doing a detailed written
budget and both of you are not agreeing
on it
because you're just taking broad swings
at these numbers as i'm asking you these
questions that's number one number two
uh she and you are not on the same page
on how important it is to get out of
debt
and there is no intensity it's just
something you're kind of wandering along
poking at
i absolutely agree with the second uh
thing the first one
we do actually have a pretty good budget
um well you suck at it
because out of 235 000 you only found 60
000
freed up i know you need to tighten that
puppy up that tells me there's no
intensity
you were you were right about that for
sure yeah that's what i meant that's why
i thought you didn't have a budget
because that's not enough i mean you
should here's the thing
if you guys i think if you were if you
were intense and both of you were dialed
in
and you were willing to sacrifice i'd
say you keep both cars
pay them through you're going to be done
really really fast it's only 70
000 bucks out of 235. you should have
that done in like
nine months or eight months and then
yeah i wouldn't move down out of that
car making that kind of money
i'd stay right there in that car and you
like the car you did say that
so um i would agree with her then i do
not agree
with her not being intense on getting
out of debt
and thinking you're gonna wander your
butt out of it in the next three years
making a quarter of a million dollars a
year so her suggestion with her lack of
intensity don't go together
so you need to decide which one you're
going to be if you want to be intense
and focused and be done with it in seven
or eight months
keep them both and pay them off and both
of you roll up your sleeves and get on
beans and rice to get this mess cleaned
up
and then you've got more than 790. you
got her car payment your car payment
no payments all of that to invest and
you move right on up into baby steps
you will free it up and that's really
what you ought to do yeah but if you're
gonna
wander around in this crap for three or
four years
and just be you know half butt doing it
then
you know yeah sell the car sell it all
show her car too yeah but i think you
know sam you sitting down and talking
with her and finding out what's the
hesitation
what's the thing that's going on and
really get connected like you guys
you've got too much of an income
coming in to be wandering around in this
situation and here's the problem
if you don't put some guidelines in
place you guys will add a boat
a motorcycle and a bigger home in a
matter of years
and you look up and you will really be
wondering what happened so it's time to
wake up buddy
you guys get connected this will turn up
the heat you guys going to get on the
same page on that part of it
and because the problem is you're
running out down two different tracks
and so you're coming to two different
conclusions
and and that you know that's what's
happening so there's there's not a right
or a wrong answer
in in this moment the right answer is
when we get on the same track that's
going to give you the you're going to
have a parallel conclusion then
and uh you'll both be going yeah sell
the car or don't sell the car i don't
think you need to sell it i think you
need to get
both of you get intense both of you get
sacrificial and just get the dadgum mess
cleaned up that's what i would do if i
were in your shoes
hey man we appreciate you listening
thanks for calling in